Now that we have a deeper understanding
of the relationship between maximum
matching and max flow problems,
we're ready to understand
a more sophisticated algorithm.
Back in the maximum flow lecture,
we considered two ways to improve
over the naive Ford-Fulkerson.
One was to prefer heavier
augmenting paths.
Ones that pushed more flow
from the source to the sync.
In the max matching context,
this doesn't make much sense,
because all augmenting
pats have the same effect.
They increase the matching by one.
The other idea was to prefer the
shortest augmenting path, and there was
Dinic's further insight that the breadth
first search need only be done when
the shortest path length changes,
not once for every augmentation.
Pursuing these ideas gives us
the Hopcroft-Karp algorithm.